earlier in the day First Lady Melania
Trump called the opioid epidemic the
worst drug crisis in American history
that wide-ranging discussion at a town
hall in Virginia shows how the first
lady is speaking out more in public
wishes Jang is at the White House with
more mrs. trump's revealing comments we
should good morning good morning Nora
the first lady was promoting her b-best
campaign but she took a few off-topic
questions as well she spoke about
everything from her taste and holiday
decor to a topic that is typically
off-limits her son I'm also here as a
mother speaking to students at Liberty
University in Virginia
First Lady Melania Trump stressed her
initiative that includes combating
opioid addiction and cyberbullying I
know when I started we'd be best and
with social media initiative that I will
be criticized but I will do but what is
right for the next generation mrs. Trump
urged the importance of being kind and
respectful on social media in most cases
sometimes you need to fight back I'm
sorry the conversation took a personal
turn when she brought up her
twelve-year-old son Barron I discussed
with him I teach him what is right what
is wrong even shedding some light on
what keeps him busy he doesn't have a
social media yet he's not interested in
it he's all into sports
mrs. Trump is usually guarded about all
things barren and limits our public
appearances but in recent months she's
kept a much higher profile taking her
first international solo trip all over
India spreading her anti-bullying
message and even shaking up
administration personnel after publicly
calling for deputy national security
adviser Mira Ricard el to be fired mrs.
Trump also opened up about life in the
White House including the new Christmas
decorations that Twitter users mocked
with the hashtag blood trees a
description she laughed off we are in
21st century and everybody has a
different taste I think they look
fantastic
this morning mrs. Trump heads to
Argentina with the president for the g20
summit when asked if she'd be sharing
her experiences in an autobiography she
said with what's going on in her life
she could write a lot of books john
weecha thank you the proposals will be
coming in shortly from book publishers